there is some news from the world of  televised sports I should mention this  I'm very sorry to report the guy who  invented television instant replay died  Sunday at the age of 81 oh that's sad  the guy who invented television instant  replay died Sunday at the age of 81 oh  that's sad the guy who invented  television instant replay died Sunday at  the age of 81 oh that's the guy who  invented television into replay died  Sunday at the aedra date  wait this is kind of disrespectful yeah  you're right I'm sorry  wait this is kind of disrespectful yeah  you're right I'm sorry  wait this is disrespectful yeah you're  right I'm sorry  this is kind of illegal use of a referee  to end a sketch five-yard penalty loss  of down thank you very much  [Applause]  you